why do you have this unicorn man I am
building an a swiping robot I'm thinking
that's like the pinnacle of shitty
robots
my name is Simone yecch
I am the CEO and director of a company
named artificial stupid
[Music]
when I started building things obviously
I was pretty bad at it can't be good at
things from the start and I decided just
to embrace that and roll with it and
turn it into something funny this is a
workshop and where I live I can't help
but notice all this stuff right away
right here what's that guy right there
this is the first shitty robot that I
ever built so it's a toothbrush helmet
it was a microcontroller and Arduino
board here and then there's a server
field I just started building these
things and I posted them online and I
think reddit is where it really started
taking off that's where the queen of
sheba robot started I owe a lot to
reddit somebody must owe that title on
me I mean I embraced it too I can't be
like totes reddit is it's like a tiger
it's great if it's your friend but it
can also eat you alive what else is up
on this table here a dremel tool some
plastic hands really cool kinetics and
it makes your finger smell terrible
though snow kind of rubbery can I show
you the ice waving robot I haven't known
how to shoot it because I obviously
can't use my own butt and it actually
has like the flattest ass ever it's not
fully done yet here's the servo motor
it's going to have a toilet paper roll
you press the button and the servo motor
turns down and you just make toilet
paper fly everywhere
do you want to see another project so
this is a package opener
the final version the scissors are going
to open further I'm still working on the
strength I think actually what's been
hardest for me with building these
projects is the mechanical aspect of it
because it's a lot trickier than you
would think it's a lot of the same
circular motion I've been thinking about
using linear motors but I avoid anything
that can be interpreted as a
machine because that's what everybody
comments no matter what I built it's the
truth if you work on the internet and
you're a woman
Janice see this so I have a fig tree in
the backyard and it was really hard to
reach the figs so I wanted to build an
arm extender there you go you can grab
things that like this little actually
all this did was like crushed the figs
because they're very soft I got a little
goldieblox action figurine she's a
really cool inventor my role model I was
thinking about people walking on the
streets like in looking at their phones
and especially when people were playing
a lot of pocket Mungo
so I thought for one you can use a
helmet to protect your brain but also to
suspend your phone in front of your face
so you can look at your phone and walk
my favorite jud suit is this one what's
that NASA won from a follower Allah sent
me her Space Camp suit I feel so good
when I write it oh this is just great I
started making this charging station for
my phone that's like a little cage phone
is in the cage now don't play with it
Simone I built the robot version of
jenna Marbles dog Kermit it turned out a
little bit worse than I had anticipated
[Music]
this is the first woodworking project
that I did in a really long time 32
layers of plywood for days to make it
was a lot of work so this is the
pinnacle of narcissism because I just
put my own name on it do you still have
some of your more well-known robots I do
yeah my top video is probably the wake
of machine and that one was the first
one
started going really viral it's an alarm
clock that stalks me in the face with a
rubber arm oh and here we have the
applause machine and it's one of my
favorite projects because it's just like
very happy
[Music]
the lipstick machine I did a thousand
layers of lipstick it just moves the
servo motor back and forth listens to
the button that's on top and it puts it
out on a matrix display it's fun and it
feels great but I also just feel like a
traveling circus this is probably the
most political project I've ever done
it's a grabs back machine so I
built this with my friend whose name is
Laura Kampf so her workshop was close to
a sex store so it was like a fisting
hand and the way I strapped it to my
waist was a strap-on harness I actually
haven't told that to anyone before
put these Ella brackets so that it stops
in the right position yeah so I just
like touch yeah and yeah cuz he grabs
back this is doomsday I didn't really
realize how terrifying it was going to
be it was innocent enough I just wanted
something that helped me chop vegetables
and then I realized like wait this is
actually going to have knives flinging
so the way the Tropic machine works is
that there are two servo motors continue
servo motors so they go all the way
around what I wanted to get was a very
forceful motion and that was what was
tricky because you could just have it be
attached directly to the motor but then
it's just going to go up and down and
you're not going to get that slam I got
a lot of comments on it
the chopping machine is the perfect
response whenever somebody sends you
dick pics you don't want
what else you got so this was the first
project that I built together with Adam
Savage this is a popcorn element it kind
of pokes me in the eyes but that's the
trade-off as much as the shitty robots I
build and what I do is just a form of
comedy I think it's also important to
show that failure is a part of the
process it can sometimes be the end goal
people are very obsessed with building
useful things and I think often that
also stops people from getting started I
want people to build things and to
actually fix the things that they have
around them just allowing yourself to
spend time on what you're enthusiastic
about I used to be a very duty driven
person and now it's like I'm completely
driven by what I enjoy doing my life
could have taken so many different paths
and I'm just so happy that I'm on this
like jackpot of the path I can't think
of anything I'd rather do
[Music]